connected again after more than a year
of silence
and with inter-korean relations at a
standstill
north korea cut the line last june in
protest against defectors
launching propaganda balloons from south
korea
relations hit such a low the north
destroyed the liaison office which had
been set
up with the south but it's been
confirmed the leaders of north and south
have stayed in touch throughout
exchanging multiple letters
the two leaders also agreed to work to
regain mutual trust
and foster progress on relations again
south korean president moon jae-in has
made restoring relations with the north
a cornerstone of his administration and
with less than a year left in office
he's determined to get dialogue back on
track
a sentiment the south koreans shared
with the north in this first phone call
since the inter-korean communication
liaison lines were restored today
i hope we can continue to deliver good
news
to the rest of the world this
announcement coincides with the 68th
anniversary
of the signing of the armistice the
brought fighting in the korean war to an
end an event marked by north korean
leader kim jong-un
visiting a cemetery for his country's
war dead
north korea has in the past used the
cutting of the hotline
as a way of showing its displeasure and
with its restoration now
it seems similarly upbeat on the
prospect of
improving ties stating the whole korean
nation
wants relations to recover from what it
calls setback and stagnation
also motivating north korea could be the
multiple crises it faces
years of sanctions compounded by food
shortages from damaging storms
and isolation because of the pandemic
provide
compelling reasons it seems to pick up
the phone to its neighbor
rob mcbride al jazeera seoul